>>> WE'RE CONTO FOLLOW
THE AG NEWS  WE' SHERE.
MAEN'S WARD IN THE SOUTHERN
MARIUPOL.
UKRANIAN PRESIDE ZHIARE NO M NE.
WE HAVE LO HERE.
JOININ RIGHT NOW IS ANALYST TOO.
IT'S KEY C TRTF
BE TARGET?T'S AN ARETHABSOLU P
TGEND
SHOULD BE OFF TLEMPISS OBVIOUSL
TERE
.S ARE TYPICAL
WHAT THESI
EXAMPLE, IF EN T
IS ABSOLUTELY NO WAY IH
E NS A
N THONAL STANDARD TARGETING
E SHOWING RIGHNO
YOU MIGHT NOT E USE THIS IS BRA.
I'SEA DIFF
PERSPECTIVE OF OUTSIDEY LARGYOUN
IT'S SHOCK SIN
LOOKINAT THIS.
PI, CH WULL EVERYONE ABOUT RUSS
D DECLARE UKRA
THAT THE NOW PAR
ATLETELY.
HE HAD NO IDEA TTHLDESATS REALFE
POPULATIONHEING TO MAKE
OP.E PIO TAKE OVEND CLAIM THOSE.
NEY THHEET OF THE POPULATION, R
HA.IT I
THSEN SYRIEY
WERE ACTIVELY OW
HOSPTHEY WRDINATES
LS FROM THE U.N.
AND TARGET THEM ON.A STSI
TARG IT WE
SH K FORHA
>> BEFORE WE MOV TO THE NE
A NOTIAN , AND WERE T NOT
PAINE IS PAWNS IN IT
OPE THIS ISN'TIDENT ZELENSKYY S.
AEN
ZELEY BA
IGHT, TH
ALSO PART OF THEUSSIAN WAY BACI
BACK TTSRUS EXACTLY WHAT THE AND
ITA COMPLETE VIOON
IMPROCEDURES.AW AND STANDARD
YOU  THESE COUNTRIES BLU IWH AS.
O .ME OFHEHERE
'SLS
DEG HEADQUARTERSS
FORC
POLAND AND ROMANIA D ND NWI A
TED IN EUROPE.S OU WU
S MA
POWER HEADING ?
W KATE, WHALOOKING AT IS A DEP.
WE'RE DOTHS A  WARN AT I
ONE STEP INTO A NATO UNTRY THATL
ICLE OF THE EA
THAT IS WHAT WE'REIT'S SOMEWHAT
WELL AS THE SECOND GULR,
TH I IS RTOMTING PROCEDURE, F FT
O SUSTAIN FOR .
H AWAY AND  PUTIN'S IG ANDTI
WE CAN PUT THE MAP UP, GUYSBEST
UCH,
NATO U SE
TO RUSSIY RAOBVIY  CENTE
SDWLT
.
WAS THIS A MAJOR MISCALCULATN OS
>> YTHINN WATORUMP D HTTIONS FR
DIVIDED AND WOULDN'T BE ABO
UNITE  DLLIN
PERMANY, PEOPLE IN FRAE, PEOPLE
INUROPE, ANDCO T UITEMINDS EVER
HOD R COME BACK AND
NATO WAS ENCOURAGE